i have this big
fear i think of getting
locked into doing things that aren't
actually the most impactful things and
to me this is like the trait that
entrepreneurs have is they just have
this like
laser-like ability to go find where they
can have the most impact and you know
when you take on a new project
especially if you hire people or start a
company you're doing that project and i
mean there are ways there are obviously
different ways that it can exit and all
that but
i think having the flexibility to
explore a lot of different things which
you can do when you're in college which
is one of the amazing things about being
in college is you can work on all these
hobbies
and encode a lot of stuff and try a lot
of different things it's this amazing
flexibility that i think most people
take for granted and once you decide
okay i'm going to start a company and
i'm going to do it with someone else you
immediately now need to convince someone
else if you want to change your mind on
something and i think people really
undervalue the option value and
flexibility